astronaute québécois david saint-jacques
d'un métier nouvelle pour la première
fois aujourd'hui quatre jours après son
retour sur terre à l'issue d'une mission
de six mois dans l'espace il avait bien
meilleure mine aujourd'hui vous l'avez
noté
il reprend donc des forces entouré de sa
famille au centre spatial lyndon johnson
de houston au texas
ses trois enfants ont accueilli leur
papa avec des étoiles dans les yeux
comme l'expliquent sa conjointe
véronique morel avec qui j'ai parlé un
peu plus tôt madame morin bonsoir bon
enfant merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je dois vous avouer qu'on est
un peu rassurés d'avoir vu monsieur
saint-jacques aujourd'hui david saint
jacques en pleine forme très loquace
très vivant dans sa conférence de presse
parce qu'on était un peu inquiet quand
il a débarqué de la capsule soyouz
comment se porte-t-il depuis quatre
jours mais comme comme n'avait pu voir
une porte très bien il y est je dirais
que de jour en jour même dans la mare on
retrouve le le david de qu'on connaît le
temps s'est fait bien son oeuvre avec
elle à la gravité à plus de 100 corps
est en train de se réadapter à la vie
porteur et il dit à chaque battement de
coeur ça va mieux mais il prend encore
sont bêtes plutôt que de prendre une
douche à cause de ses problèmes
d'équilibré s'assomme la fois depuis
quatre jours sa vie et votre vie alors
dans d'abord le 1er 24 heures dont david
et atterri dans les steppes du
kazakhstan qu'à partir de là ça prend 24
heures de transit pour tous est rapatrié
il a été rapatrié ici à houston où je me
trouve présentement en chantier à mener
il a été amené bon y atterrit de tarle
en fin de journée le 25 donc ma vie on
est on a été emmené dans toute la
famille on est venu passer la nuit dans
un indice sur site
johnson space center qui s'appelle croix
2 s'écoule et où les autres ne viennent
que pour l'heure la réhabilitation
on a dormi dans sa famille pour la
soirée des heures jusqu'à très tard ou
entre très tôt le matin des tests donc
les hôtels et les scientifiques veulent
avoir donc le temps tout de suite après
l'arrivée de l'astronaute est entré sur
toutes les questions à être c'est fait
les autres noms sont très occupés ont
passé la nuit ici on ne puis déjeuné
ensemble le lendemain matin qu'il avait
des partis pour une autre journée de
tests qui ont été assez chargé puis a pu
rentrer à la maison donc une mercredi
soir puis tranquillement on reprend là
ont remis dans la vie on reprend la vie
normale depuis par les journées sur le
site de la nasa puis mais ils capables
de vendre est quand même là mais vampire
reprendre la 30e place et comment vous
avez des opa de jeunesse de jeunes
enfants comment ils vont réagir le
retrouve et on avait les enfants et
était bien préparée en tout comme à
chaque voyage ou à chaque sortie on
rêvait toujours en famille elle se
quittaient pas les attentes
quels conseils outils on avait quand
même perdu depuis plusieurs jours des
effets de la gravité sur le corps de
papa on savait à quoi s'attendre
les enfants savaient bien que
l'équilibré fragile alors quand avant
d'entrer on est accueilli david les
enfants prêts à entrer dans l'avion qui
l'amenait aides avaient dans leur avait
dit de ne pas tourner la tête de papa
lui donne un bijou de faire attention
c'est pas de parler avec une voix douce
de marché ils ont été très très prudent
très correct très concentré mais ce soit
qui avaient des étoiles dans les yeux
étaient très contents de voir le pian
c'est aussi qu'on tende le pouvoir
l'aider les garçons lui ont tenu la main
pour qu'ils défendent à viande ce
bizarre que nous faisons il faut qu'on
s'en occupe un peu comme de notre petit
de la plus petite c'est ça parce qu'il a
des problèmes
oui oui absolument oui oui il se
rappelle des deux camps la candeur de
toutes parts a appris à marcher
plus tard qu'au niveau au niveau de
l'estomac c'est un peu fragile autour
alors alors ouais il faut qu'ils
réapprennent à marcher comme un come
baby par l'endettement il dit monsieur
saint-jacques dit en conférence de
presse ce que au moment d un journaliste
lui a demandé ce que vous allez vouloir
manger une poutine par exemple il a
répondu non ce que je vais manger c'est
de la bouffe familiale donc il veut être
à la maison il veut être avec les siens
puis entouré cocoon est absolument ce
qu'on recherche actuellement c'est la
vie normale de ce qui est précieux tout
petit short on prend pour acquis
o'leary fort le soir manger du pâté
chinois elle est vraiment là la petite
vite que bien entendu qu'ils ont manqué
de même pas les derniers trois communes
comment vous avez ah oui parce que on
pas beaucoup des six derniers mois mais
c'est une aventure de trois ans pour
pour vous et pour les pour lui pour la
famille comment vous avez vécu six mois
dans l'espace
avez vous des contacts avec lui comment
ça se passait oui absolument
on avait d'abord on est quand ils
viennent en train de vie pour gérer
l'absence non parce que c'est les
commissions sont préparés pendant trois
années
david a passé deux années à être plus
lente arctique à la maison alors tout là
toute la gestion des maisons les les
dynamiques familiales et dynamique
d'absence la communication aussi on
avait pu tester si l'on veut plus faire
de plusieurs manières de s'adapter à la
pente alors les pendant les six mois
c'est ça qui s'est mis en oeuvre c'est
tout notre réseau qui parce qu'on avait
une solide qui était très présent ça c
est ça s'est passé très bien parti puis
on s'est bien adapté à la fin
côté communication david est en
communication constante avec moi ma clé
plusieurs fois par jour j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression de m'être un ancrage pour
lui mais aussi de vivre de vivre la
mission de manière estime le quotidien
très bien et bien c'est lui le de notre
part
tout le monde ici est très fière de lui
mais dites lui que on n'est pas sûr
qu'il va pouvoir marcher incognito dans
les rues de montréal comme il le
souhaite parce que il est
véritable étoile ici madame au rêve
merci beaucoup nous avons parlé ce soir
ça fait plaisir bonne soirée